So tomorrow on the show, I am going to talk about
a new poll. This is not some wacky poll. It is
a serious poll from a good pollster that has Joe
Biden 21 points ahead of Donald Trump nationally.
And I'm going to tell you, we should pretend as
though that poll doesn't exist and we have to
go and vote. But that's tomorrow. Today, I want
to talk about Arizona. There is a stunning new
poll. This is out of Arizona where Joe Biden is
reportedly ahead of Donald Trump by eight points,
which is Biden's largest lead in Arizona in recent
memory. Now, of course, this is just one poll in
an average of recent polls. Donald Trump is now
trailing Joe Biden by three point four points on
average in Arizona. Still nothing huge, nothing
certain. But that eight point lead in the latest
poll, the only poll that we had recently, is very,
very important. And in similar news from Arizona,
sort of in the same poll, Democratic challenger
Mark Kelly is leading incumbent Republican Senator
Martha McSally by 11 points. That polls Mark
Kelly's lead to an average of six point six. There
was a debate, I believe it was last night, between
Mark Kelly and Martha McSally, cringe worthy
performance by Martha McSally. She was actually
asked multiple times because she's kind of been
a Trumpy, right? She was asked, are you proud of
what Donald Trump has done? She refused to answer.
It was absolutely cringe worthy. She embarrassed
herself. And the reason that these polls are so
compelling and noteworthy is that if you look at
the history of Arizona in presidential elections,
you see that the last time a Democratic
presidential candidate won Arizona was 1996.
That's 24 years ago when Bill Clinton defeated
Bob Dole and won the presidency. And before 1996,
the last time a Democrat won Arizona was 1948.
In the last 72 years, a Democrat has only won
Arizona twice. If these numbers were to hold in
Arizona and Joe Biden wins by three, four, five,
six, seven, it would be a signal that it is going
to be a very bad night for Donald Trump. Now,
on the other hand, if it goes differently, it
could be a perfectly fine night for Donald Trump.
Important to know for our friends in Arizona,
the last day to register to vote in Arizona was
Monday. So that date has passed other important
dates. Absentee ballots are being mailed out
to day. October seven, early in-person voting
will begin very, very soon. Dates and hours may
bear vary based on where you live. Contact your
county for details about in-person early voting
locations and hours operate of operation. The
last data request a ballot for absentee assuming
you're already registered, will be October twenty
third. Weekend voting will happen on October 24th
and very, very important for our Arizona friends.
If you. Plan to mail your ballot. You have to mail
it by October 27. Must be postmarked by October
27. This is very important in some states.
As long as you mail the ballot by Election Day.
It will count. That is not the case in the very
important state of Arizona. You must mail the
ballot by October 27. And then, of course,
November 3rd, in-person voting, election day,
every single state. We will be there. So what do
we take away from these new polls in Arizona that
show Joe Biden in an increasingly strong position?
They show Mark Kelly in an increasingly strong
position against Martha McSally. The polling
tells us only that we have an opportunity to make
some real change here. The polling tells us that
we must vote. The polling tells us that our vote
can actually make a change happen in our country,
that if you imagine a big cruise ship, very,
very difficult to redirect. Takes a while. Right?
Big, heavy, massive object. We're trying to
reoriented a few degrees, just a few degrees.
If you leave the Port of Boston heading towards
Europe, a few degrees of difference here is the
difference between ending up in the UK versus
ending up in Morocco. All right. That's the
metaphor. That's the analogy, please. And thank
you. Let's all vote. Let's all make this happen